and Eric Palacios from Eric Palacios and
Associates the sponsors of this segment
explains what the penalties are for your
first DUI charge
hi I'm Eric Palacios welcome to the
legal minute today's question is what
are the penalties for a first-time DUI
charge if you're found guilty of a DUI
there are many penalties first you will
likely spend between two days and up to
six months in jail you'll have to
perform 24 to 96 hours of community
service you'll have to attend DUI school
and pay fines between 400 to 1 000 you
also have to attend a DUI Victim Impact
Panel where you have to listen to people
who've been personally affected by
someone drinking and driving on top of
that your license may be suspended for
up to 185 days with your blood alcohol
level is above a 0.18 then you will face
even more penalties if you're accused of
driving Under the Influence it's
important that you call an experienced
attorney right away I'm Eric Palacios
this has been the legal minute you gave
Eric Palacios and Associates a call or
visit their website at Eric
palacioslaw.com we'll be right back